das hier ist das perfekte Fried Chicken
so saftiges chicken bekommst du
eigentlich gar nicht zu Beginn brauchen
wir natürlich etwas chicken da bieten
sich vor allem diese Hähnchen
innenfilets an davon habe ich ein paar
wenn ihr allerdings normale
Hähnchenbrust bekommt ist es auch kein
Problem die könnt ihr dann einfach in
Streifen schneiden zack schon habt ihr
im Prinzip auch diese typischen
tenderpieces unsere chickenstreifen
geben wir jetzt in eine Schüssel und
dann übergießen wir sie mit Buttermilch
jetzt würzen wir die mit Paprika
cayenpfeffer weißen Pfeffer Salz wer
will eine Prise MSG jetzt das ganze
verkneten allein das sieht schon nach so
viel Geschmack aus jetzt über Nacht
marinieren lassen oder solange wie du
Lust hast unser chicken ist mariniert
kümmern wir uns um die Panade hier drin
ist einfach nur Mehl und ich füge ein
wenig geräucherte Paprika weißen Pfeffer
cayenpfeffer und eine Prise Salz hinzu
einmal durchrühren und dann können wir
unser chicken auch schon aus der
Marinade ins Mehl geben gut bedecken und
das marinierte chicken gebt ihr dann die
Friteuse oder ein Topf mit heißem Öl und
jetzt fritieren bis es goldenbraun ist
und wenn unser chicken fertig ist dann
geben wir es zum Kühlen auf ein
Gitterrost schaut euch das einfach mal
an in 0 kom n hat man so selbstgemachte
chicken tenders